vous dire mais des vidéos une prière le
son des soupes des bijoux puis après
souliers de complète parce que c'est
moins cher ses jours célia cote
désormais ses jus avec de l'eau question
de les maximiser ce mélange lui permet
de faire quelques économies petit mais
essentiel son budget étant
particulièrement serré avec un revenu
annuel de 30 mille dollars et une
hypothèque à payer seul couvrir les
dépenses courantes et de plus en plus
difficile et je ne peux pas citer les
choses que j'étais habitué à acheter non
avoir un peu cheap au début quand on
peut les petits pots des produits
laitiers et les poissons on ne le pense
pas même la quantité médicament est
réduite au minimum malgré une récente
opération au dos dans l'île et les prend
quatre fois par jour le boire il a vu
lol on est capable des landes où un
petit peu plus d'entrain ça va être
diminuée louise cordeau fait et lucie
d'importantes concessions ces temps-ci
plus de 50% de ses revenus qui totalise
20 mille dollars par année serve à payer
son loyer pour y arriver dans le
contexte inflationniste
elle réduit ses portions chf 2 qu il me
plaît je fais quatre ponts avec je fais
plus juste de rapports avec les coûts du
logement et de l'alimentation qui
augmente louise ne dépensent plus du
tout pour se faire plaisir vous skiez a
suscité que durable c'est certain j'ai
pu témoigner
les sorties au restaurant
selon ce planificateur financier
les ennemis comme célia et louise sont
parmi les premières victimes de
l'inflation à la retraite généralement
on contrôle plus rarement les revenus
les dépenses seulement en travaillant on
peut changer d'emploi on peut avoir une
autre emploi tu avais plus par les
limites donc je sortais contre au sommet
revenus
à la retraite souvent merlimont et fixe
d'après les données de la fadoq les
individus qui reçoivent strictement la
pension de la sécurité de la vieillesse
et le supplément de revenu garanti du
fédéral touche dix neuf mille neuf cent
cinquante dollars par année 50 % des 65
ans et plus ont des revenus de moins de
27 mille dollars et plus de 35 % gagnent
moins de 20000 dollars
la fadoq demande quant à elle que soit
bonifié de 10% la prestation de la
sécurité de la vieillesse pour les
canadiens de 65 à 74 ans comme elle l'a
été pour les plus de 75 ans il souhaite
style du provincial qu'on propose c'est
de mettre en place une conçoit une
subvention ou encore une couverture par
le biais de la régie d'assurance
médicale du québec la rancune pour
assurer des soins dentaires ou en cavale
l'achat de lunettes prescrites ou encore
deux appareils auditifs celui que ce
sont des dépenses bien importante que
bien des élus ne peuvent pas se payer
mais d'ici à ce que de telles demandes
soient entendus célia souhaite que ces
conditions vie et celle des autres eni
soit radicalement améliorée puisqu'elle
n'a plus d'alternative point couper des
pelouses je ne fais pas ici et met le
mieux radio canada montréal